let us now revisit the second
calculation that we carried out in the
context of our earlier example in that
example we calculated the total
probability of an event that can occur
under different scenarios and it
involves the powerful idea of divide and
conquer who are we we break up complex
situations into simpler pieces here is
what is involved we have our sample
space and our sample space is
partitioned into a number of subsets or
events in this picture we take that
number to be 3 so we have a partitioning
to three possible scenarios it is a
partition which means that these events
cover the entire sample space and
they're disjoint from each other for
each one of the scenarios were given
their probabilities if you prefer you
can also draw this situation in terms of
a three there are three different
scenarios that can happen we're
interested in a particular event B that
event B can happen in three different
ways
it can happen under scenario one under
scenario two or under scenario three and
this corresponds to these particular sub
events so for example this is the event
where scenario a1 happens and then event
B happens as well in terms of a tree
diagram the picture becomes as follows
if scenario a1 materializes event B may
occur or event B might not occur finally
we are given conditional probabilities
that event B will materialize under each
one of the different possible scenarios
under those circumstances can we
calculate the probability of event B of
course we can and here's how we do it
first we realize that event B consists
of a number of disjoint pieces one piece
is when event B occurs together with
event a1 another piece is when event B
occurs together with a2
another piece is when event B occurs
together with a three these three sets
are disjoint from each other as we see
in this picture and together they form
the event B therefore the probability of
B is going to be by the additive 'ti
axiom of probabilities equal to the sum
of the probabilities of these sub events
furthermore for each one of these sub
events we can use the multiplication
rule and write their probabilities as
follows the probability that B and a1
both occur is the probability that
scenario 1 materializes times the
conditional probability that B occurs
given that a1 occurred and then we're
going to have similar terms under the
second scenario and the similar term
under the third scenario so putting
everything together we have derived at a
formula of this form the total
probability of event B is consist is the
sum of the probabilities of the
different ways that B may occur that is
B occurring under the different
scenarios and those particular
probabilities are the products of the
probability of the scenario times the
conditional probability of B given that
scenario now note that the sum of the
probabilities of the different scenarios
is of course equal to one and this is
big because the scenarios form a
partition of our sample space so if we
look at this formula here we realize
that it is a weighted average of the
conditional probabilities of event B
weighted average of the conditional
probabilities where these probabilities
of the individual scenarios are the
weight in words the probability that an
event occurs is
average of the probability that it has
under each possible scenario where the
weights are the probabilities of the
different scenarios one final comment
our derivation was for the case of three
events but you can certainly see that
the same derivation would go through if
we had any finite number of events but
even more if we had a partition of our
sample space into an infinite sequence
of events the same derivation would
still go through except that in this
place in the derivation instead of using
the ordinary additivity axiom we would
have to use the countable additivity
axiom but other than that all the steps
would be the same and we would end up
with the same formula except that now
this would be an infinite sum over the
infinite set of scenarios